So that ties together this, what constructed E does
for you, and connecting it to the hardest examples.
So now, that gets us to a nice little
trick where we can talk about how we actually output
our final example. So, the way you construct your
final example, they way you do that combination in the
step is basically by doing a weighted average. And
the weight Is going to be based upon this alpha
sub T. So the final hypothesis is just the s g n function of the weighted sum of
all of the rules of thumb, all of the weak classifiers that you've been picking
up over all of these time steps Where
they're weighted by the alpha sub T's. And remember,
the alpha sub T is one half of the natural log of one minus epsilon T over
epsilon T. That is to say, it's a measure of how
well you're doing with respect to underlining error. So, you get more
weight if you do well Then if you do less well or
you get less weight. So what does this look like to you?
Well its a weighted average based on how well you're doing or
how well each of the individual hypotheses are doing and then you
pass it through a thresh holding function where if its below zero
you say you know what? Negative and if its above zero you
say you know what? Positive and if its zero you just throw
up your hands and And return zero. In other words, you return literally
the sign of the number. So you are throwing away information there, and
I'm not going to tell you what it is now, but when we go
to the next lesson it;s going to turn out that that little bit of
information you throw away is actually
pretty important. But that's just a little
bit of a teaser. We'll get back to that there. Okay so, this
is boosting, Michael. There's really nothing else to it. You have a very
simple algorithm, which can be written down in a couple
of lines. The hardest parts are constructing the distribution, which I
show you how to do over here, and then simply bringing
everything together, which I show you how to do over here.
>> Alright yeah, I think it doesn't seem so bad
and I feel like I could code this up, but I
would be a little happier if I had a handle
on what the, why alpha is the way that it is.
>> Well there's two answers. The first answer
is. You use natural logs because you're using
exponentials and that's always a cute thing to
do. And of course, you're using the error term
as a way of measuring how good the hypothesis
is. And the second answer is, it's in the
reading you were supposed to have done. [LAUGH] So,
go back and read the paper now that you've
listened to this and you will have a much
better understanding of what it's trying to tell you.
>> Thanks
>> You're welcome. I'm about helping others Michael you know that.